um
the tripod and you could do hand held
that's probably pretty good too
if you want to roll around
yeah wondering how
is
if any of you are able to push back like
a footer
we don't have enough room for the
speakers to come in from the side so we
need to have a little more space up
front
i'm really sorry i know you're all set
up if there's any way to just push back
like
two feet it would be incredibly helpful
thank you so much
really appreciate it can we move this
camera back whoever this is
okay thank you thank you very much
we're gonna have fun
um
bye
okay one two three one two one two one
two
works for me
oh
[Music]
yes
am actually gonna be the first one
i'm actually gonna be the first one to
speak so i'll fix it for me but then
[Music]
i don't want to like
is
basically sorry there's a lot of
figuring um
the members of congress want to make
sure that things are covered safe and
they have space when they're up here
pressure
can we can we move a little smooth six
feet from
hey everyone is this on it's not
actually on is it all right
hello everyone because you know we are
obviously in the middle
of a pandemic right now
and we have some people coming in and we
need to have at least six feet of
distance between where i
am and the first row of people and we
actually need to have
a way for them to enter where they're
not on top of people so we need everyone
to move like
three feet that way in order for us to
be able to do this so they feel like
they can safely come
i i feel like we can do this together
with some teamwork
go team we got this
i'll get out of the way
do you feel comfortable though you're
back
yeah um if carrie came over to talk to
the camera directly
would that be okay yeah that's okay and
then that's how we'll go live
oh there she is
um
i like your um
hey tim um we're about ready to go live
we have a emcee who's gonna kick us off
okay
are you gonna keep that on for the
interview yeah okay
so we can hear you here
are you ready and then he'll queue us
first
can you hear us
um
think
we're homeless
welcome hello can y'all see me
[Music]
hello perry we are really about to start
if that is okay
[Music]
i'm excited too hi everyone my name is
chatterjee i'm uh the executive director
of u.s climate action network
uh our first speaker to welcome us is
ashley nicole mcclay
who is the green new deal
organizer with the indigenous
environmental
network so please join me in welcoming
ashley
my name is asha nicole mcrae i'm an
enrolled tribal member of the absentee
shawnee tribe of oklahoma
i'm also oglala in chichangu lakota i'm
here representing the indigenous
environmental network
alongside all of our allies our friends
our accomplices and our sister
organizations
to demand bold action now our
communities are suffering
along with the climate crisis only being
exacerbated by a global pandemic
our folks on the front lines are
fighting hard every day
to change this system so i just really
want to take this time to ground all of
our relatives
and remind all of our relatives why
we're here
that we're here on stolen indigenous
land that we are
facing a battle of neoliberalism
of colonization white supremacy and
capitalism
that is harming and killing our
communities and to just remind
folks that we need to center and uplift
indigenous knowledge
not saying that we have better solutions
just saying that we have lived here on
this land
in relationship with all of our
relatives since time and memorial
and maybe we have a good road map toward
the future that we would all like to see
and i really am so excited that our
congress folks are here
especially recognizing that
congresswoman aosp
predicated and was inspired to run for
office
by joining the front lines of our
indigenous relatives at standing rock
we're fighting the dakota
access pipeline so this beautiful
marriage
of our allies in congress and our
frontline grassroots folks
is really the way to move forward toward
this path of a regenerative future up
next i would like to invite my sister
tashina sapohi smith
a co-founder of the cheyenne river
grassroots collective
to come share some of her knowledge and
some of her words and experience
she is in south dakota right now along
with our communities
fighting on the front lines against
keystone xl pipeline
not only that but fighting the many man
camps to exact
violence against our women and our
communities
so she is here as a warrior with the
full delegation and i'd like to go ahead
and invite her up now
[Music]
hello my relatives my name is uh tatina
and it's translated into black shawl
woman i am from the cheyenne river shoe
reservation
this is my son kian and i am a
co-founder of the cheyenne river
grassroots collective i'm also a
community organizer with them as well
uh i think we can all agree that the
last four years have been utter [ __ ]
and because of this we are here now to
speak to the dmc and call out biden to
stick to his foreign policy plan
her racial equity racial equity
uh climate justice public health
and uh economic prosperity
so part of what we do with the uh shine
river grassroots collective is we
monitor
the workflow of tc energy's keystone xl
pipeline
uh right now we have boots on the ground
who have been
uh checking out the work camps or better
known as man camps where thousands of
construction workers from out of state
will be flocking there to earn a buck
now these man camps when we've been
documenting
they are not following cdc
recommendations they don't wear masks
and that
brings poses a threat to our community
our indigenous communities
uh on cheyenne river we barely have the
manpower or in the resources to
tackle covet so that's one of our
biggest concerns too along with the
missing and murdered indigenous rate
or indigenous peoples rate uh when that
skyrocketed
when these man camps are put near
reservation borders
so we also empower our communities to
get organized and to start fighting back
about these injustices that
have been happening to our people for
over 500 years now
we are a strong resilient nation on
cheyenne river
and we know that they it is a strategy
and a tactic that they're using
to be there right by our borders all
along the case keystone xl pipeline
route there's
little to no activity except by cheyenne
river
there are now four man camps and
it breaks my heart every day to watch it
happen watch them
already dig up the earth and try to go
under our rivers and waterways
so what scares me the most about this
though
is that we were given information by a
credible source
that will remain anonymous that an
unclassified document
written by the national or the south
dakota national guard and it
in the provides personnel and equipment
and
to assist the county and state elected
officials
in an elected official response to the
tc energy pipeline construction
within that document they have already
made a plan to use lethal force
we've read this document we we and it
it's terrifying because we are
as the cheyenne river oyate
we do everything in our power to try to
protect our people
to try to protect our children's future
to try to protect the earth
the water the land the air it runs in
our
blood it's our resilience that has been
keeping us alive
it is us being out in the streets every
day or at
the pipelines every day to make sure
that we can still
thrive so that we can still grow as a
nation
we always ask ourselves what kind of
ancestor do we want to be for our
descendants
and i want to be like crazy horse who
fought and died for his people
who fought and died to protect what
little we have left here
now so i'm going to ask aoc i'm going to
ask the democratic
national committee committee i'm gonna
ask biden
please put an end to this fossil fueled
addiction
put an end to this ongoing and genocide
put in an end to the
ongoing injustices against our people
because we will stand
and we do know that there are people
willing to put their bodies on the line
to make sure that our future generations
will have a clean
beautiful in in just
thriving communities and i want to say
won't be like tonka to all of you who
are here today
to make sure that our frontline voices
are being heard
because we're running out of time and we
need biden to stop it now
thank you i'd like to
i also am going to introduce a margaret
with the grassroots global justice
alliance so give it up for margaret
[Music]
oh thank you for that hi my name is
margaret quanton
um i'm with the grassy's global justice
alliance i'm the great new deal national
organizer there
i thought i'd start us off with a little
bit of call and response
so i'm going to say care jobs are and
what i want you to say is
green jobs so i'm going to say hair jobs
are
hair jobs are great care jobs are great
care jobs are ready all right so i feel
like i could do that
all day um so what i'm going to talk a
little bit about is
one uh the context that we're in to the
type of transformation that we need
knowing that we are building the power
to make that happen
so i think as so many folks have already
said we are at
the crossroads of many intersecting
crises
that have only been exacerbated by this
pandemic
so thinking about structural racism
thinking about the economy
and unemployment the kovid crisis has
only made
these things worse and at the root of
many of these crises
is actually the need to prioritize
profit over
people so while we're thinking about why
the coveted crisis
got so bad we can point directly to
the desire to have businesses make
profit and to stay open
rather than spending the money and the
time
to support people with resources to stay
safe
that same logic has been what has
exacerbated the climate crisis
the desire to continue to fuel
extraction
over protecting life and protecting our
communities
so given that this is the point we're at
i think the question is
what has been made more clear in this
moment and how are we going to respond
to it
and one of the things that's been made
more clear in this moment is
who is really at the heart of our
economy that makes it function
these are our essential workers these
are our teachers our domestic workers
our workers in the care economy that are
caring for our loved ones
for the elders for our children for our
disabled brothers and sisters
it is so incredibly important that we
are lifting up those folks as we
march on to a new economy so
to continue on what the solution is it's
it's us investing in both um
in both an economy that cares for the
planet in ukraine
union jobs uh that are going to
prioritize clean water and clean air
while also investing in green jobs that
are care jobs
that are caring for our families
and we think that the green new deal and
the thrive agenda is able to put a down
payment on the type of economy
that we need it's our economy that
centers
life over profit a type of economy that
is
anti-racist in nature that is
prioritizing
communities of color and rectifying past
harm done
an economy that is feminist in nature
that is recognizing
the unpaid unseen work that so many
women and fans are doing
in their homes every day and an economy
that is regenerative
one that is uh investing in
renewable energy and also a new form of
agriculture
that is not doesn't have the same rate
the same havoc on our earth
so that's why we're here today is that
we're demanding that you know biden be
brave that he step up to the plate
because we have the solutions in our
communities
we know that this work is important and
that's going to be incredibly important
in whatever new economy that we build
and so we're saying
this the the green new deal and the
thrive agenda are
part of making a down payment on the
type of world that we need
an economy where we're centering life
where we're choosing to thrive
thank you and so i'm gonna
introduce john henry with the sunrise
movement
[Applause]
thank you so much um like you said i'm
an organizer with the sunrise movement a
regional organizer and i'm here to tell
you a story in 2008
my father a man who would walk around
the house singing civil rights songs and
who had dog bites on his arms
and who went to work every day
died of a major coronary while walking
my mother home from her job as a
waitress
and the nurse who stopped on the side of
the road to give him cpr
was probably some of the only health
care he received
in the later years of his life and i had
a choice
at that moment was i going to give up or
was i going to get up
and i got up and i helped my mom
file the tax returns so we could afford
to bury my father i helped find his
military paperwork so we could bury him
in a national cemetery
i planned the funeral and i remember my
twin looking me in the eye and saying
john you haven't cried why haven't you
cried
and i stared back at him and i said
because there is work to do
in 2019 a decade later i was working
three jobs in los angeles and still not
having enough
to pay rent i was cursing the fires that
were burning from the amazon
to los angeles and i was driving to my
friend's mansions
meanwhile passing tent camps of homeless
people on the streets
and i was sick of going back and forth
to work pretending like everything was
normal
knowing i was living in a society where
my political
leaders had failed me and again i had
the decision
was i gonna get up or was i gonna give
up
and i got up and i threw my stuff in my
car
and i drove across the country here to
washington dc where i joined
the sunrise movement and in 2020
in the middle of a global pandemic while
the police continue to kill black people
in this country
and hurricane after hurricane is
battering
our country we have the decision are we
going to get
up are we going to give up and i am part
of a generation
of black indigenous latinx people of
color who are getting
up who rose by the millions to help
get joe biden elected and who helped get
these green new deal
champions we are going to hear from in a
minute elected
people who took to the streets and we
are asking you
to stand by your promise to us and i
want to use barack obama's words
it is time to pick ourselves up shake
ourselves off
and begin the work of rebuilding america
but this time
let's build it for black people let's
build it for indigenous people
let's build it for youth let's build it
for justice and not build it for money
let's build it alongside
the organizers and my friends gather
here two years ago
we stood here as a sunrise movement and
we asked
nancy pelosi to form a green new deal
committee
today we are asking president-elect joe
biden
to form a select office on climate
mobilization
treat this crisis with the urgency it
deserves
treated with the urgency of a mother in
lake charles
who's homeless for the second time this
year with the urgency
of the california farm workers working
under soot
blood red filled skies and treated with
the urgency
of the middle schoolers who made
millions of calls to get you elected
if you do that we will never forget you
and if you fail
us we will never forgive you you guys
and i
it is my immense honor to bring an
activist
and congresswoman elect corey bush here
to speak
so yes so thank you all for welcoming me
thank you for inviting me
to this moment so first of all
i think that we need to make sure that
something is very clear
when we don't act people who look like
me die
so let me say that again when people
don't act people who look like me die
and so there is just no other
alternative right now
than to make sure that we have bold
leadership
and some people say oh well you can't
win or you can't
you have to play this game well i'm done
with the games we can't play any more
games because when we played the games
people die what we're looking at right
now when we cross the mark
for 250 000 people dying
at the hands of trump's covet 19
and i'm calling it trump's clover 19
because this could have been done
differently
so we're looking right now to
president-elect joe biden
to make some changes and do some things
that are different but it's not good
enough to just do
different we got to do bold we got to do
change that happens now we got to make
sure that black folks browse those every
marginalized group
our indigenous folks feel our change and
so that's why we're here
we need change that everybody can feel
and so yes we're going to get in good
trouble doing it
yes we're going to make sure that we say
the names of those that have passed
because of a failed leadership and so
that's what we're asking for
right now when i think about the
day when i didn't care about the climate
i see one thing you all know about me is
i tell my own
ish i don't need somebody to tell it for
me there was a day when i didn't care
about the climate i thought the climate
crisis and
climate issues was all about or caring
about the environment was about
recycling and and endangered endangered
animals well i tell you what
i found out after
fighting about why is my energy bill so
high
fighting about why do i keep having to
go to the hospital for asthma
why does my child have to keep going to
the hospital for asthma
and then i realized that it's these coal
companies and it's these
it's these companies that are the ones
that are
pushing this into our communities into
communities that have nothing to do with
it
that are the most impacted who look like
me when i think about my district
where black children are 10 times as
likely to go to the er
asthma than white children we got to do
something about it
so we're calling on dividing
administration right now to save lives
service laws there's no other
alternative we need bold leadership and
we're asking you because we voted for
you
black and world communities showed up
ilha no more
and our sister right here and rashida to
leave showed up and made sure that
people are
sure enough to vote so we're asking you
to show up for us
and we need it now thank you
[Applause]
how y'all doing such a pleasure and
honor to be here with you all
very humbling to be standing amongst you
as a congressman-elect representing new
york's 16th district
[Music]
you know our first evening here
majority leader stanley hoyer took us on
a tour
of the capitol and took us into
what we often referred to as the
people's house
but i couldn't help but feel a certain
sense of
anger and frustration
and guilt because i didn't feel the
people's house
was representative of the indigenous
people of this country
i didn't feel the people's house
really captured how
african slaves built this country
with their hands for 244 years and
haven't earned a dime as a result of
that work
the people's house didn't capture that
for me
and as i stand here amongst you and we
talk about the need for climate justice
and pushing back against environmental
racism
i dream along with my sisters and my new
friends and family members in congress i
dream of
the rebirth of america and i dream of a
country
that we are going to rebuild together
that is representative of all of us
and all of the people of this country
not just
white men at the top harnessing and
exercising power
and continuing to fund the fossil fuel
industry
which is literally destroying the planet
and killing us
i dream of a world and i i i can't wait
to get to work
in building a country and building a
planet that really represents all of us
and works for all of us so in my
district
in my district in new york 16 it's a
majority minority district
and part of that district represents the
bronx along with my sister congresswoman
ocasio-cortez
and if you live in the bronx you are
three times more
likely to die of asthma than anywhere
else in the country
my district is also surrounded by water
we have the henry hudson on one side and
the long island sound on another
and right now in yonkers which is part
of my district
we have raw sewage leaking into the
henry hudson on a daily basis
on the other side of the district in
mount vernon we have
raw sewers leaking in to the long island
sound
which is going upstream into aoc's
district
so this is an urgent matter that we have
to deal with
we are living in the climate catastrophe
it is impacting my district like
districts across
across the country and i want to add
this very important point
after world war ii after the great
depression
we implemented something called the new
deal
and the new deal built not just a white
middle class
but it built white wealth in this
country
120 billion dollars invested over a
30-year period
to build white wealth 98
of those loans went to white people
african-americans were excluded
the latino communities were excluded
indigenous communities were excluded
joe biden has pledged a two trillion
dollar investment
in environmental justice and 40 percent
of that has been pledged
to districts like mine across the
country
so that 40 has to be a part of a green
new deal
that rebuilds black and brown
communities across this country
in parts of my district we have pockets
where the poverty rate is as high as 30
percent
we need jobs we need infrastructure and
we need those jobs to go to black and
brown communities
black and brown communities organized
across the country to make sure
joe biden won the white house and he did
that
but now it's time for payback and now
it's time to make sure that we invest
the resources necessary
to rebuild our nation in a way that is
representative
of all of us so we can truly have
the people's house thank you so much god
bless you all
it is difficult to go after my brother
the congressman-elect
jamal bowman who would have thought
prior to this year
that in 2020 westchester county would be
represented by not one
but two black progressive members of the
united states congress
and the fact is this progressive
movement has been defying expectations
every single day yeah
it is a joy and an honor to be standing
alongside
movement leaders organizations
like sunrise and the green new deal
network
members of congress for whom i have
tremendous respect
and yes soon to be members of congress
like the amazing cory bush and jamal
bowman
[Music]
[Applause]
climate change is happening all around
us
fires have been burning up the west
coast of the united states of america
droughts increasingly increasingly
have been leading to food and water
insecurity
hurricanes are proliferating
and they're not just devastating the
gulf coast where we're used to seeing
that
they're devastating communities like my
home county of rockland new york
where hurricane isaiah's plunged 100 000
households into darkness
climate change is real and for the first
time
in our lifetimes we have the opportunity
with a biden harris administration to
avoid and avert climate catastrophe and
ensure a livable future
not just for ourselves but for our
children and our children's children
and that is thanks to the work that we
have been doing for a long time
i am excited to build back
better and to pass the most
robust ambitious climate proposal
offered
by any major party nominee for the
presidency of the united states of
america
we've got to fight like our lives depend
on it because they do
we've only got 10 years left on the
clock before irreparable damage to the
planet
and so we can't afford to
change the margins we gotta make sure we
undertake the big structural work
globally to make sure that we have a
planet that we can inhabit
a few years from today i'm excited to
roll up my sleeves with all the folks
behind me
and with all of you in front of me by my
side
to continue that important
long-suffering work
and my goodness don't the folks in
congress of good conscience now having
reinforcements
i'm excited to be joining the most
progressive
and most diverse congress in american
history the 117th congress
i'm excited to work with a president
elect and a vice president-elect who
have centered
environmental injustice or rather have
centered environmental justice
as racial justice i heard
congressman elect jamal bowman talk
about his district
and we are discovering and experiencing
many of the same challenges
just north of his district in central
and northern westchester and all of
rockland and of course all throughout
the united states of america
i'm excited to work with you all i'm
excited to fight alongside you
and we will win this fight thank you
[Applause]
thank you so much thank you thank you
let's hear for corey bush who
started us up with the house down let's
hear it
the pride of new york right now mondaire
jones and jamal bowman
let's hear for people who have been in
this fight rashida to leave and johan
omar
and to the man who really helped and
partnered
in in making sure that we start this
whole thing off senator ed
markey of massachusetts along with
all of our other partners fighting for a
green new deal
you know it's um it's it's really
emotional i found myself getting
emotional
hearing corey and jamal and monday
monday
actually represents um the district
where i went to elementary school
he represents the district where i grew
up in public school
and um it's really it's so emotional to
hear him
talk and champion these issues because
growing up
as a little girl i never ever saw
any elected representation that
even really thought of me let alone
looked anything remotely like me
and to think that we could fast forward
and
we have champions like monder jones and
jamal bowman
and corey bush they're now being ushered
into this wave
it shows that these issues are not a
fluke
it shows that they are not a flash in
the pan
it shows that they are not a hot new
thing what it shows
is a deep yearning for climate justice
and environmental action in the united
states of america
it shows a deep commitment to climate
change it shows that
this isn't 2015 anymore
this isn't 2010 anymore it's not 2005
anymore
climate is now a top three issue for
voters across the country
and it's about time that our congress
and our administration
starts acting like it way past time
well what i think is so important is
that every single person up here
represents the power of the movement it
represents the power of indigenous
communities
organizing the power of young people
organizing
the power of the movement for black
lives organizing
showing that climate is intersectional
with every one of our needs and demands
it is tied to the treaty rights and
liberties of indigenous peoples in the
united states of america
climate action is tied to reproductive
justice
because we can't talk about poison water
without talking
about how so many people across their
country across this country
are denied the right to build a
biological family
because they've been poisoned by their
own water we can't talk
about climate unless we're talking about
the rights of young people
to have a habitable planet unless we're
talking about the rights
of working class people to have a job
that get that guarantees them dignity
and it's only bold federal action that
can guarantee
these things it is only that kind
of transformational investment now we
have worked
and the movement has pushed the movement
is why i was elected to congress the
movement
is why jamal and corey and monday are
here today
you all the movement is why ilhan is
here the movement is why rasheeda is
here
the movement is why ed markey was
protected
this year it was a movement
because as we've been saying since day
one
they've got money but we've got people
[Applause]
we've got people and at the end of the
day
dollar bills don't vote although they
try to
we vote people vote young people vote
and it's about time long past time that
we recognize
and understand that we owe our seats
we owe our political power because of
young people because of the movement for
black lives because of women because of
the working class across this country
and it's it's a class issue it's a race
issue it's a gender issue
that's why this work is so important and
because of the movement
and the power that the movement has
built over a million calls
were made in texas alone over a million
calls
we had calls made for jamal you know how
many calls were made for you in your
raise
yes how many
there you go the movement made a million
calls for jamal bowman
so don't tell us about what young people
can and can't do
what the movement for black lives can
and can't do but the movement for
climate justice can and can't do
and because you all have done the work
you all got to succeed at the table we
have worked
with the biden administration to secure
commitment on a two trillion
dollar climate plan two trillion dollars
but we're not going to stop there we're
not going to stop with a piece of paper
that's not what's going to happen we're
not going to forget about that agreement
for the sake of an election are we no
what we're going to do
is that we're going to organize and
demand that this administration
which i believe is decent and kind
and honorable keep their promise
so that's what that's what our next move
is
to make sure that the biden
administration keeps
its promise kept its promise to young
people
kept its promise to the movement for
black lives kept his promise to
communities and working-class people
across the united states of america
that's our message today
to keep your promise and so
we know that we don't just make that
demand and walk away
we have to organize for it we have to
bring the heat
for it because there's a whole lot of
people
that tried to just shove a bunch of
money before this election
to try to buy their seat at the table
but we organized for hours
and we're not easily going to let that
go so our demand here is to make sure
that we keep this promise that we follow
through on a
visionary absolutely unprecedented
2 trillion plan that's not just about
money
but also it's one of the first
presidential plans to honor the treaty
rights of native people
they're one of the first rights to make
sure that we have environmental justice
front and center
so we that we make sure that we make up
for redlining that we make up for flint
that we make up for baltimore that we
make up for lead
in the pipes across this country so
that's what this movement is all about
i want to thank you and i don't want
anybody here
to think that we're not winning because
let me tell you something
we're winning it's working it's
happening
and we are going to secure a future
we're going to secure
the basic tenets of a green new deal a
multi-trillion dollar
jobs program for climate for
environmental racial
gender and clash justice that's what the
green new deal is and we will stick to
that plan so thank you all so very much
[Applause]
hey everyone i don't care i think we
look really good
including you senator murphy um we not
only look good but we speak truth to
power
and i'll tell you you know sister alc
said it you know we're
we're already one you know why because
they can't get rid of us
we're everywhere it's true i swear to
god every time i turn around some of my
colleagues come up to me and said can
you talk to those sun people i said you
mean sunrise
i was like that movement is not going
anywhere you went through a generation
of a movement folks maybe anti-war civil
rights labor rights movement you
remember senator parkey
this is a movement of people we're not
going anywhere
but let me tell you what's incredibly
important here
is that you know as you all see up here
it's going to be our lived experiences
that really have us be able to get
credibility within the
halls of congress and in my district
where i grew up in southwest detroit i
honestly thought that smell was normal
i honestly thought that my friends
having asthma was normal because they
normalized it
but we're here to tell them that's not
normal that is not normal to watch
people
have to put respiratory machine on their
six-year-old child
because she can't breathe because of
corporate but the pollution is so bad
i have family members that call me all
the time and tell me what are we doing
here
we're giving them the permission to kill
us permission to pollute
and when i look and talk to our young
kids and when i'm always reading them
books and everything i always ask them
at the end
how many of you all have asthma and a
third of them a third of them raise
their hands
they're living with so much pollution
some of them can't even go to their
fountains covered in plastic because
there's so much lead in the water coming
into their schools
so it's important as we talk about this
movement as you see us all up here
that we put the human face to what it
means to do nothing
about our climate crisis what it means
to do nothing about dirty air and dirty
water
and so i ask all of you to continue this
movement to give credibility to us
because when they decide to do nothing
when they decide
maybe this is not the moment i want you
all to show them show them what the
images if it's an indigenous brothers
and sisters
it's those suffering from whatever is
happening globally
and the migration that's coming in our
country understanding all of it's
interconnected
but i'll tell you when i met
with president-elect biden in detroit he
said you know i'm going to need your
help i said sir
i'm going to help you get reelected
don't worry about that because the
people are going to come out because
they know the importance
of protecting our country and our
democracy but i said
you i might not be your favorite member
of congress
because my timeline is different my
timeline is different i have no time to
our folks don't have another day another
hour another any moment
another week a month they're tired of
waiting they've asked you for clean air
they have asked you for clean water to
protect them
and so we're going a different timeline
and we're going to make sure that
the biden administration sticks to our
timeline is moving towards our timeline
and so
i ask all of you do not move
from the needle do not we are more
than them and let me tell you as we beat
the drum as loud as we gonna get
and it's going to continue to be we
understand this movement is more than
one day
it is more than election day this
movement
is more than ever in the election day it
is
about people and about transformational
meaningful action around climate crisis
thank you on behalf of my seniors my
residents
they know i'm a crier but you all know
representing the third poorest
congressional district my residents
can't come up here
they can't afford it they can't afford
to leave their homes so you young people
i want you to know this
you are speaking on behalf of so many
people in my district
that need your voices here i will bring
them into the halls of congress into
committee
but you all being here is inspiring them
they love that you are speaking the
truth about
the injustice that they've had to live
with so for so long so thank you for
that
thank you for your partnership thank you
hello everyone um
i'm excited to see all of you i know
everybody has talked about what this
movement has meant
and for me i've been really excited
because i represent a district that has
just
had 88 turn out
this election cycle
and i know that there was a massive
increase in rashidus and there's been
massive increases
in districts where for generations
people have tried
to get people to come out and
participate in our democracy
and for the last week and a half
everyone has asked me what happened in
your district ilhan what do you think
is the reason so many people came out
and participated in this election
and for me it's very simple it's about
the invitation we put out to people
and why they needed to participate
because the invitation
was about electing someone
who was going to invest in building
our country back better and so
as soon as the election was over and
we've seen all of these people who
participated
because of that invitation we have seen
the pundits and some of the leaders
within the democratic party
or even some of our colleagues who are
um freshmen talk about us getting back
to basics
saying you know the squad alex ilhan
rashida all of you have to stop
talking about everything you talk about
because we need to get back
to basics so i was confused because i
thought
what is more basic than fighting for
clean water
what is more basic than fighting for a
breathable
planet what is more basic than trying to
make sure we get health care for people
what is more basic than fighting for the
people
you represent knowing that
you represent districts where there are
pockets
where the children in that community
have the third highest asthma rate
what is more basic
than fighting to make sure that here in
the united states
black women should not die
of maternal mortality rate four times
higher than their white female
counterparts
what is more basic than trying to make
sure that there is
transportation and transit
and that there is sustainable
communities
and making sure that we are inviting
people
to set the agenda instead of
corporations and special interests
what is more basic than trying to make
sure our indigenous
brothers and sisters don't use don't
lose their sovereignty
and and that we fight to stop things
like
the um the pipeline in in minnesota and
trying to make sure
that we are not prioritizing the fossil
fuel industry
what is more basic than trying to
protect the future of our children
so people will talk about kitchen table
issues
and everything that we fight for
to me is what my family discusses
at the kitchen table that is what your
family discusses as the kitchen table
this is why this movement is so exciting
because we know that a green new deal
is not just some platitude it's not just
some conversation that's cooked up
in the basement of some corporation
this is a conversation a movement that's
built
out of the urgency that people feel in
wanting to protect
our climate and our planet
so as a daughter of a 17 year old who is
part of this movement
who got excited at the age of 14 because
she realized
that that 10-year mark meant that her
eight-year-old sister
might not have a future to look
forward to when she graduates high
school
so as rashida says we are working off a
different
timeline the urgency we feel
is very different than the people who
turn a blind eye
to the ticking time bomb of this climate
crisis
and so i urge you all to continue
raising this issue because we hear you
we are here with you and we stand by you
and every single day that we spend
in congress will be a day devoted to
this movement and the things that we are
fighting for to have a better future for
tomorrow
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you representative omar thank you
to all of you
for your passion and persistence thanks
to you we have all these amazing
new members who are going to fight for
climate change
we've got a senator elected with a
mandate
on climate change and you know i
remember when
this was just starting and
representative ocasio-cortez the
boldness to meet with the sunrise
movement and all of you
and you stayed with it for two years
outside the dnc
when we didn't have a climate change
debate boy were they wrong
boy were they wrong not to do that and
we see now
that young people mobilized around the
climate but it was not just an
issue of a livable planet and not just
an issue of justice it's an issue of
jobs and i think we have to
make very clearly the argument that
a climate policy is a policy that's good
for the economy
the fastest growing jobs the fastest
growing jobs in the country
are solar panel installers and wind
technicians
and energy efficiency manufacturers and
you know where these jobs are
these jobs just aren't in california or
new york or massachusetts
turns out these jobs are in ohio and
pennsylvania
and wisconsin and michigan and so when
they say
that the environment or the green new
deal
is an anti-economic policy they don't
know what they're talking about
the brand new deal and what we're
fighting for
is a policy to put the working class
back to work to create good-paying jobs
to create jobs in the parts of the
country that need those jobs the most
we have the facts on our side we have
the argument on the our side
they have the rhetoric on their side
they have the slogan airing on their
side
and the only thing that will beat
sloganeering the only thing that will
beat rhetoric
is all of you because when you go out
and you're armed with the facts and
young people have the most facts that i
know i saw this with the parkland kid
you know
all the statistics you have all the
evidence and if you
mobilize and you demand that we have an
office
of climate mobilization and you demand
that we have a climate policy
as an economic policy then i know
in this administration we're going to
get it done
and actually make progress to tackling
climate change thank you for being out
here
[Applause]
thank you ro so thank you all for being
here today
uh we are no longer
in the era of incrementalism
we are in an era where fundamental
change
must take place if we are going to save
our planet
when alexandria and i introduced
the green new deal in february of 2019
it was called pie in the sky
it was called politically infeasible
it was called unrealistic
and then we had
an election in 2020
and the sunrise movement rose up
and injected itself into race after race
across our country and reinforcements
are now
arriving in congress corey
and jamal and wander all represent
this revolution
changing the way in which people see
the issue of climate change
in our lives and this isn't a matter of
moving to the left it's a matter of
doing what's right that is what happened
that is what people saw over
the last two years young people
rose up and young people voted in
unprecedentedly high numbers
and their number one issue was the
climate
crisis alexandria
talked about my race in
2018 in massachusetts 18 to 34 year olds
represented 12 of the total vote
in 2020 it represented 19
of the total vote and their number one
issue was
the climate crisis and so
there's an iou there's uh
there's a debt now to these young people
because they
did rise up they did the right thing
they played by
the rules and what they know is
that the planet is dangerously warming
and there
are no emergency rooms for
planets and they also know that we can
solve this problem
by massive deployment of wind and solar
in all electric vehicles
and plug-in hybrids and battery storage
technologies
and energy efficiency and energy
conservation technologies
and we can create millions of new jobs
we can save
all of creation by engaging in massive
job creation that is what we are going
to do
and we know and we know
that in the biden plan
a two trillion dollar plan that 40
percent
of the funding is going to be designated
for communities of color that 40
of the money is going to be dealing with
the obvious reality that black and brown
communities have always breed
different air than white suburban
communities in the united states of
america
and we can see that in the corona virus
crisis where black and brown communities
close to the pollution have the highest
levels of
coronavirus as well because they're both
respiratory
illnesses we can see that
and so we're at a moment right now where
the fossil fuel industry
is descending on washington dc and they
want to call the green new deal
socialism and you know what our answer
is
what do you call 100 years of tax breaks
for the oil and the gas and the coal
industry
and what we're saying is give us the
same brakes
from wind and solar and all electric
vehicles and plug-in hybrids
and battery storage technologies and we
will bury
the fossil fuel industry that is what
this fight
is all about we are going to take them
on
every single day we are going to make
sure
that those young people those sunrise
organizers realize
this political payback that they have
fought for
and so for me uh this is the moment
and these new incredibly great leaders
are coming over the hill as the
reinforcements
because there has been not just a moment
but a movement that has changed our
country and it's going to continue
to change our country so we're just here
to say
that we want and we ask joe biden
to be brave to be big
to be bold to ensure
that we put in place the kinds of
policies
that are going to fundamentally
transform
the relationship which exists between
the people of our country and this
climate
and that we do so with intersectionality
we do so with communities of color
at the front of the line we do so
recognizing the historic injustices
and that we take what was considered to
be
a pie in the sky proposal the green new
deal
that alexandria and i introduced two
years ago
which does not seem so crazy any longer
because it will create the jobs that we
need
and it will provide the justice that our
country has been
desperate to have for generations thank
you all so much for being here
we are going to have just a few minutes
of q a after
our hey song we're about to sing a song
called we're standing for our futures if
you know the song
sing along if you don't know it listen
and then sing in when you figure it out
right we are standing for our futures we
are healing what is wrong
we are standing for our futures and
together we
are strong we are standing for our
futures we are healing what is wrong
we are standing for our futures and
together
everyone we are standing for our futures
we are healing what is wrong
we are standing for our futures and
together we are strong
we are standing for our futures we
are healing what is wrong we are
standing
for our futures and together one more
time
we are standing for our futures we
are healing what is wrong we are
standing for
our futures and together we are
strong
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you so much all right we're going
to take a couple of questions now
right here i have a question for
congresswoman okay
cortez if i might you've laid out a very
ambitious policy agenda here are you
concerned
that the president is trying to derail
progress for the party and it could be
critical
well you know i'm not concerned about
the president trying to derail
uh progress for the grassroots movement
i am concerned about the fossil fuel
industry
trying to derail progress for our
movement i'm concerned about
exxon mobil trying to derail progress
for our movement but
you know when we first introduced us as
senator markey said when we first
introduced
uh the green new deal at the beginning
of this most recent term
we were told everything from it's
unreasonable to it is
beyond the pale that um that these
provisions
are are unrealistic but now you fast
forward to the end of this term and
they told us we couldn't repeal fair
cloth in the house
and we did they told us we couldn't get
past x amount of sponsors co-sponsors on
this legislation
we are now past 100 co-sponsors in the
house of representatives
on the green new deal resolution they
told us that we couldn't get union
support
we told we couldn't get union support
from building trades
on climate action and lo and behold we
have union support on the green new deal
for public housing to massively invest
in infrastructure in this country
there's a lot of people
on both sides of the party a lot of
democrats saying we can't do what we've
already done
a lot of people are saying that it is
not possible so again i'm not concerned
about this president's commitment
i am concerned about the voices and the
industries and the lobbyists
that could infiltrate and and really
kind of
poison the ability for us to have
progress which is why we have to
con convene and keep the pressure on
thank you
what is your assessment so far of how
biden has uh
approached this issue he appointed this
week cedric richmond to his white house
team
he has some fossil fuel connections what
do you see so far and and
what do you think that tells you about
how he'll go forward
president-elect biden has constructed a
two trillion dollar
infrastructure program that is green and
he asked for the sunrise movement to be
a part of
the construction of that plan
and it is the boldest plan that any
presidential candidate has ever
put in place and so from our perspective
we are ready to fight in order to make
sure
that that plan becomes reality and that
the fuel economy standards which donald
trump
has rolled back are put in place that
the appliance efficiency standards which
donald trump has rolled back up put
back in place and expanded and made even
bolder
and and i i know that when
joe biden talks about this is these
issues he says that he is committed
to rolling back all the trump
environmental
uh policies uh in moving forward and
moving forward boldly
okay and so that's what we are doing we
are we are here to say that we
are uh committed to ensuring that the
boldest
policies are put in place uh
and we are very hopeful uh that
with our efforts and the momentum that
we have created that that will be the
case
next year uh in the biden administration
appointment doesn't worry you at all it
doesn't concern you
two quick questions i know that before
the election
there was a lot of um unity with
progressives working on the task forces
is there still conversations and work
happening with the transition team
in private not just these public
demonstrations and secondly
it's not just the plan that he's put out
as you all have said it's not just a
paper it needs to be more than that
what's one or two things you need to see
from president-elect biden or vice
president-elect harris to know that
they're actually serious about getting
this done
all right a couple questions there
sure um yes you know i um
i had the the privilege of serving on
the climate unity task force
uh with with the biden team and you know
to your first question on transition
there is open communication uh between i
i think uh just many
parts of the party including the
progressive wing of the party um
and you know i think in terms of what
we're going to see on the seriousness
of abiding harrison administration on
climate are uh
their appointments uh and our in their
transition so you know it's not just
about one figure or one person
but we need to see the a broader level
um in the overall tenor of transition
appointments because
we know that in transportation is a
climate issue we know health and human
services is a climate issue so we want
to see in
every cabinet appointment if what the
disposition towards climate is
and how the how uh the biden harris
administration wants to approach climate
uh and and who they put in so i think
it's it's really the amalgam it's
the orchestra and the harmony of those
appointments to understand them how
serious the administration is
thank you
thank you oh hi
my name is carly um first of all i
apologize for my pajamas i was in bed
and i saw you guys were doing this and i
came
um my question is for you actually
representative it is
as a young democratic socialist
obviously i worked with bernie sanders
campaign obviously it's very
heartbreaking that we didn't get that in
office
and i think a lot of us are feeling very
lost at the cabinet selections and
things that biden is doing at this point
especially his position on fracking
um what exactly can young people like
myself do
to really ensure that we hold right and
accountable and in four years we don't
end up with
another passage like donald trump okay
i'm sorry um you know i think where hope
is
is that if you're if you're and i say
this as an activist as well
if you're only looking at electoral
politics you will get cynical
and upset and turn away and just
want to fold and give up so my advice to
you
is to not rely on electoral politics
we need to have that's why we operate as
um
as as in an inside outside strategy
that's why you all send us in there to
have all of these very frustrating
um you know type of struggles well you
all
keep keep doing the the hopeful work of
organizing
and you know if you want to know about
whether it's fracking or any other issue
just look at the movement that emerged
at standing rock
look at the movements that emerged
around flint look at the movements that
emerged
in in our home state of new york where
grassroots movements
successfully um attained a moratorium
and then a ban
uh on fracking and so you all
don't forget the power that you have and
do not
think that we have to rely solely on
elected officials for change
we are partners in this we are not above
or below at each other
in this
[Music]
um you guys have said that you're not
necessarily worried about
obama administration derailing some of
these progressive proposals but
you guys are all democrats you know
protesting outside of your party's own
headquarters
it's very likely there will be a
republican senate uh even with the biden
administration
why not for instance do this outside of
the rnc or the nrsc
versus here in front of your own if
you're on can you give your name an
outlet yeah it's ramsey with newsweek
i don't i don't think this is a form of
protest it's building public support
and this is something that is so
important i hope we win the two georgia
races
but if we don't the house should pass
bold policies and we should have
the administration mobilize around the
country for those bold policies
that is the uh aspiration what the
american people want we shouldn't be
compromising with ourselves
uh or with mcconnell so when you see a
movement
outside the dnc we're all part of the
dnc we're not protesting ourselves what
we're saying is
this is what the democratic party wants
it's not opinion it's fact i mean fox
news says
polls out there showing overwhelming
support for medicare for all
overwhelming support for the growing new
deal
it's only in washington that these
policies are considered
difficult so this is saying this is what
the democratic party believes
and we have as much a right to the
democratic party mantle and
articulating those views as any other uh
elected person
and i think this is going to be the last
question and we do have movement leaders
who are going to be interviewed right
around the corner over here and would
love for folks to
direct questions there after we wrap up
here thank you this is for any of the
members of congress um i wanted to ask
you yesterday you all re-elected
speaker pelosi as a caucus to be uh
speaker for the next
two years for the 117th congress uh
are you guys concerned that she is not
going to champion the same policies that
you want over the next term
uh no no that's not that's not a concern
of mine and
uh and i i can't speak for the other
members of congress
um what you know we are all
members of congress we represent
different districts we are all
here as part of um uh
as part of our caucus to bring forth um
the the policies that that we are
advocating for
and care for uh the ones that the people
who have elected
us sent us to prioritize not every
single district
shares a priority um and so our job
is to introduce the pieces of
legislation get
people to co-sign those pieces of
legislation and try to work
um to to move them through through that
process
and make the demands of of the speaker
and leadership
um to implement the the policies that
that
that we want um and you know it's a it's
a push and pull
like it is with everything else uh and
you know we're not oblivious to that
we're not naive and on the way that this
this process works
we've had many successes in in this last
congress
in ways in that we have pushed this
speaker to implement changes
in some of the key pieces of legislation
that came out of our
caucus and we intend to continue to do
that as progressive
caucus members all right
thank you all so much as i said
there are going to be movement leaders
over here for us this is about being
fundamentally
unyielding in what we need which is
liberation for our people in our
communities
and a future that is livable so yes we
do need to see these outcomes and i
really
invite everyone to please not leave
right now
when our awesome elected representatives
leave but to talk to our movement
leaders hear what's happening in our
communities
it's incredible yes how much pain is out
there
and how much we need a solution to these
interlocking crises
but also the vision that is out there
that we
hold that we will make true for a future
where we can all survive and thrive so
please join us over here around the
corner
and we'll be answering questions over
here thank you so much everyone
[Music]
is
uh
you